hakeem hussein died alone neglected
unwell and unable to wake his mother he
had an asthma attack
he'd gone outside to try to get some air
his frozen body was found the next
morning his mother laura heath had been
taking heroin
their flat was filthy smoky and cold it
made hakeem's asthma worse he used to
ask his mother to stop taking drugs but
she prioritized her habit over his
health
an inhaler that could have helped him
used instead by his mother as a
makeshift crack pipe
jailing laura heath for 20 years the
judge told her hakeem's death here was
needless tragic and the result of her
abject failure as his mother there are
now questions for the authorities too a
serious case review is examining who
knew what and the head of the birmingham
children's trust has said that social
workers missed clear opportunities to
prevent hakeem's death
he'd had three emergency admissions to
hospital and his school had made several
safeguarding referrals
two days before hakeem died a school
nurse warned a child protection
conference that hakeem could die at the
weekend
a family outreach worker from his school
voted to take hakeem immediately into
care
the meeting ended with agreement that a
social worker would speak to his mother
on the monday
but hakeem was found dead on the sunday
morning
this death of hakeem was preventable his
um his treatment for asthma
should have been should have been
routine
so it's important that all those
agencies that knew about hakeem social
services
school police
this would be subject of a serious case
review and everything that was known
about hakeem will perform part of that
and it comes down to that there may be
some recommendations for all agencies
but it's important those lessons are
learned to make sure there's no other
deaths like this but deaths like
hakeem's keep happening logan muwangyi
star hobson arthur lebino hughes all
killed by their parents and failed by
the authorities arthur's cousin says
more must be done they need to be
a reputable service like the police
where they'll step in they need more
power if they have suspicion a child is
at risk they should remove the child
the child can always be returned and
apologies can be made
we can't keep losing these children
hakeem hussein should still be alive
instead he joins a list of children let
down by a system that should have kept
him safe becky johnson sky news
birmingham